hablarán de ti cuando estés muerto
calcuta india
15 de agosto de 2016 40 grados de
temperatura y esa humedad que te va
sacando esta gotita en la espalda
minutos minutos todavía se escuchaba el
mercado afuera
y el sol ya agonizaba
pero no era el único
el estado en el tercer catre abandonado
por su familia por sus amigos por todo
algo le pasaba su respiración era tan
emplomada como esos últimos segundos
como esos últimos segundos de un reloj
de pared
entra a la escena una madre una
religiosa y jim un voluntario irlandés
yo estoy ahí sosteniendo la mano jim
saca un rosario intenta hacer algunas
oraciones mientras la madre sin éxito
intenta conectar el suelo por es que ese
hombre ya no tenía ni una vena
la respiración su respiración de vi mal
como se llamaba que el hombre se estaba
perdiendo cada vez más de pronto en esta
escena agárrala mi brazo y agarrarle la
madre y poco a poco empieza a
desencantar se del cat poco a poco
aprieta cada vez más sus ojos se pierden
en la pared de enfrente con los ojos
llenos de pasión que parecían sus ojos
antes de hecho de de su de agua en una
escena muy fuerte
yo vuelto con la madre la mami se está
viendo algo
cuando de pronto empezó poco a poco a
soltarse
primero un brazo luego otro
fue cayendo en el catre
para pocos segundos después dar su
último su última respiración
y con ello su último palpitar
yo me levanto super confundido hace un
mes había sido mi graduación aquí en
guadalajara como que ni el caso qué
hacía allí
y trató de despejar me pero cuando
regresó a que el hombre estaba envuelto
en sábanas blancas y talco y me impactó
porque digo estaba ahí qué pasó con él
habrá trascendido
si el día de hoy no es vi mal
pero eres tú quien se está muriendo
estarías realmente listo
a cómo va esto van a decir aquí viene un
tema viene de imprimir este güey no es
mi intención
pero teme la muerte es un tema muy
complicado el no volver a ver ese
familiar que tanto querías y no volver a
compartir ese domingo en familia el
cuestionarte qué pasará con mi cuerpo
después de que muera todo el tema de la
muerte es un tema muy profundo
todos estos pensamientos tan negativos
con respecto a la muerte empezaron poco
a poco a gangrena esta concepción tan
positiva que yo tenía de ella de ser
aquel a quien invitaban a dar estas
conferencias pero estas charlas así en
los clubes y más oye cómo te fue en la
india no sé qué me empezó a dar miedo
cuando estabas con estaba en las noches
y que daba este filo de luz en mi cuarto
y mi cabeza se empiece se pone a divagar
y pensar me entraba un terror nivel
fobia en pensar en la muerte ya me sé
que vino por la universidad llámese por
por la monotonía que van haciendo los
años no quizá me aleje un poco lo que
creía
me convertí oficialmente en ese 75% de
la población que al pensar en la muerte
le da más terror que esperanza
seguramente ustedes han sentido ese
terror alguna vez quizás en su cama
quizá en su soledad
esta es la razón por la que estoy aquí
con el honor de compartir este auditorio
con ustedes y es como me decidió de un
año y medio para acá el que quería
buscar cómo poder abrazar este
sentimiento cómo poder vivir tranquilo
sabiendo que me iba a morir todos nos
vamos a morir
entonces así es como empieza esta
pequeña aventura necrótica y fue de hace
un año y medio para acá la primera
lección fue bien sencilla la historia
nos ha lanzado una cantidad innumerable
de personajes que no solamente no le
tenían miedo sino que la abrazaban que
la hacían suya los vemos en los vitrales
de nuestras catedrales los leemos en los
libros de ciencia los vemos en los
cuadros de louis david los vemos en las
estatuas de nuestros parques no se
quemen gualajara y parques pero
seguramente habría estratos en ellos
personajes que no le tenían miedo que
abrazaban y me di cuenta que hablar de
la muerte es inútil si no se habla
primero de la vida y que quizá no es la
muerte lo que nos da miedo sino el vivir
una vida mal vivida una vida sin sentido
y esta fue la primera lección de esta
pequeña aventura neurótica y fue
todos estos personajes que vemos en las
catedrales que vemos en los libros
historia vivían con un sentido y un
sentido muy profundo el martirio o la
muerte fue para ellos una pequeñísima
manifestación de esa congruencia de ese
sentido con que vivían día con día por
tanto tenía que encontrarle encontrarle
en principio un sentido
la segunda lección fue un poco más
complicada porque porque no puede haber
un sentido que se trascendental y sea al
grado de dar la vida si ese sentido no
está cargado de entrega total
podemos darle sentido
a crecer un bonsai podemos darle sentido
a tener tu fornicario con tus hormiga
reina como a mí me encanta pero
difícilmente seríamos capaces de morir
por defender la música de malú ma en
cambio si te digo meterte a un edificio
en llamas sabiendo que tienes a un
familiar tuyo
luchar en una guerra para defender tu
territorio o buscar la democracia donde
no la hay ese es el sentido de entrega
total la capacidad que tenemos todos de
dar lo absolutamente todo por lo que
vale la pena vivir por tanto si muy
bonito el sentido lo que quieras pero
ese sentido tiene que estar cargado de
entrega total por tanto un sentido pero
cargado de entrega total
la realidad es que no estamos ni en
cuba' en este momento no estamos en
venezuela estamos en un auditorio muy
bonito en un hotel muy padre en una
ciudad poca madre sin parques pero poca
madre
la entrega total no es el martirio
es la vida es el día a día la
congruencia con la que todos estos
personajes actuaban con sus amigos con
su familia allí estaba su heroísmo los
brevísimos instantes por los que la
historia lo recuerda es sólo una
pequeñísima manifestación de esa
congruencia con la que obraban día con
día por tanto para perder ese miedo a la
muerte tenía que quedarme muy claro que
primero encontrarle un sentido
cargado de entrega total pero por sobre
todo en la cotidianidad como esta señora
que se levanta muy temprano en la mañana
para preparar este está malito rojo está
malito berisso tole y llevar son las
personas que están afuera del hospital
civil esta señora sabe que no va a
recibir un peso sabe que no necesita
estar ahí pero si sabe de ese cariño que
necesita la gente que está fuera del
hospital civil
lo podemos ver
como este padre de familia un taxista
que dobla turno para seguir viendo a sus
hijos estudiar
sabe que ese turno es más complicado por
el tema del frío del que lo pueden
asaltar que ya está cansado pero ese
cariño que le tiene sus hijos es lo que
lo mueve y lo hace hacerlo todas las
noches
como esta señora que visita al hospital
a aquellos que están totalmente asolados
desamparados les lleva de comer sabe que
a él le gusta este su conchita entonces
le lleva su conchita nuevamente ninguno
de los tres la vida los va a martirizar
pero viven con la misma congruencia
interior que aquellos que si incluso hoy
vi mal aquel pobre donde pone hombre en
la india que hablamos al principio nos
ayudó a darle forma este mensaje
espero con estos tres puntos
quizá no ahora pero sí cuando lleguen
esas incómodas noches puedan como yo
darle un giro muy diferente al tema
porque créanme volverán esas turbulentas
noches de la oscuridad de la conciencia
cuando va a ser la misma muerte quien
toque la puerta nuestros pensamientos
cuando la rompa solamente va haber una
salida y va a ser en vestir a la misma
muerte abrazarla bailar con ella en un
ejercicio de entrega total de dar la
vida de dar el ser de darte a todo aquel
en este momento de tu día cada pedazo de
tu vida no existe el miedo a la muerte
sino la falta de sentido de entrega en
nuestra vida
[Aplausos]